hello everybody uh my name is laurie my
pronouns are he and him i am delighted
to be invited to speak here today uh
and
i work at netlify at the moment uh where
i am a data evangelist evangelist means
i talk at conferences apparently
before i worked at netlify i co-founded
npm inc which you may have heard of
and before that a company called awesome
which i am positive that you did not
but what i am is a web developer i
started web development in 1996
and i have been in love with the web
ever since then
my goal today is to give you a sense of
where
modern web development is today
because too often developers work in a
vacuum we don't know if the tools that
we're using are the cutting edge or
they're old and obsolete
and knowing where you stand can help you
make better technical choices
they can give you new things to learn or
old tools to give up or maybe just a
warm fuzzy feeling because you're doing
the best thing right now
but how the hell do i know all of this
stuff the answer is that i asked people
in a pair of surveys in 2020 and 2021 we
got over 10 000 responses which is
really gold metal quality uh for
survey data
we use much smaller surveys to predict
national elections so
to use this to talk about web
development it's really quite accurate
but obviously no survey is perfect
netlify ran the survey and netlify is a
particular kind of web host we
specialize
in a kind of development called the jam
stack which focuses on performance
pre-rendered content on the front end
using apis to dynamically fetch data
jam stack is a very popular model for
deploying websites these days but it's
obviously not the only one
so the data is biased towards the jam
stack and also to front-end development
in general i've tried to make that clear
and i've tried to correct for it
but you should absolutely consider that
this data with that in mind
so let's start start with talking about
who we are and the most obvious thing to
ask there is what is your job
as you can see in our survey data
eighty-two percent of respondents were
engineers uh
you can also see how they split up
forty-five percent say they were
front-end end 32 full stack five percent
back end clearly this is not all web
developers uh in real life not five
percent of people are only only five
percent of people are back-end
developers so
the bias in this sample towards
front-end development is clear
uh but
that doesn't mean it's bad data if
you're a full if you're a front-end or a
full-stack engineer uh this is going to
be super helpful to you uh and if you're
a back-end engineer then you should be
taking this data with a grain of salt
our first fun discovery happened when we
tried splitting up
developers by their level of experience
and the region that they live in at the
same time we weren't really expecting to
find a pattern here at all
but instead we found this in the most
experienced group people with 15 years
of experience or more
developers were concentrated in north
america and the eu only 15 percent of
developers in that category in that
experience level came from outside of
those two regions but in the least
experienced group uh that percentage
rose to 48 nearly half
uh i love this finding because it seems
like we're watching the evolution of a
developer community more developers are
breaking into the industry from more
places
and we're hoping that this greater
geographical diversity will improve
other kinds of diversity in the web
development community as well
i was pleased to see that when github
released their octoverse survey uh two
weeks ago they found exactly the same
growth in exactly the same regions
this being 2021
we also asked developers about the
pandemic and how it's affected their
lives
excuse me i managed to catch my first
cold of the pandemic so
obviously
the pandemic has affected everyone and
everything
but we were interested about what
changes happened uh in web development
specifically we asked a very specific
question which was did your job go
remote as a result of the pandemic and
will it stay remote even after the
pandemic
and that's a very specific question but
even so 31 of people said yes
and again when github asked the same
question in their survey they got very
similar results two weeks ago
in fact the effect is even stronger when
you split people up by experience again
people who are in the first two years of
their careers were less likely to have
gone remote they were more likely to say
that they lost a job as a result of the
pandemic but past the first two years
the percentage saying that they went
remote rose to 40 percent
this is a huge huge change in the way
that developers live and work
and it's going to be years before the
true effects of that change have become
clear
so what story should we take from this
demographic data uh well you should take
it to help you understand who this data
is really about uh clearly it's about a
big chunk of web developers
but it's not going to be true of
everybody um it's still some of the best
data that we have in the industry about
the working lives of web developers
but i want to be upfront about its
imperfections
so now we know who we're talking about
what are all those folks doing
excuse me
uh there's lots of ways to answer that
question
um but the most obvious thing to ask is
what is the site that you are building
for
lots of people work on more than one
thing in a year so we allow people to
give multiple answers uh so these will
add up to well over 100
the top answer is personal sites because
you always work on your own site
but business to business b2b and
business to consumer businesses b2c
are 35 percent uh and 33 respectively it
is not news to economists that uh but i
think it's news to a lot of people that
there's as much money to be made selling
from one business to another as there is
selling from your business to ordinary
people
it's also not news to anyone that
e-commerce at 34 percent uh is one of
the driving economic forces of the web
not all b2b or b2c considers itself
e-commerce um but i think
an aspect of that that is surprising is
that lead capture all by itself is way
up there at 29 it begins to explain to
me why whenever i visit a website these
days it pops up an annoying modal
dialogue that demands that i give it my
email address
similarly huge at 29
is internal tools
uh and the story that i want you to
think about here is how much attention
do you pay to these categories how much
of your team's time is invested in
selling to businesses to lead capture to
internal tools
are you focusing too much on some things
are you giving some things too much uh
too much time and attention
and not enough to other categories what
is the relative quality of your output
in those categories
the next question we asked was about how
dynamic your site is we had options from
a totally static site to a fully dynamic
site and also single page apps
in this question we made sure to ask
about all sites not just jam's text
sites
and we had a separate question for jam
sex sites that i'm not going to talk
about here
the answer is that they're very similar
which seems like it might be a boring
answer but i think that is a fascinating
result we spend
almost as much time creating totally
static sites as we do single page apps
does it feel like we spend equal amounts
of time on the tooling for those types
of apps the huge boom in the popularity
of static site generators that i'll talk
about in the framework section seems
like it's being driven by this data
another way to ask what we're building
is what devices we're building it for
for the last few years the mantra of
thought leaders in web development has
been mobile first
you should build your website to work on
a phone first and add desktop features
later in the us 88 of consumer internet
time is spent accessing the web for
mobile devices so it seems like good
advice are we following that good advice
no we are not
desktop is the most important to us with
98 of people saying that it is somewhat
or very important as a target
phones are second at 94 which is really
close
and tablets are 91 but this gap is
bigger than it sounds because when you
ask people uh if the target is very
important 84 of people say desktop is
very important but only 71 say phones
and less than half say tablets so are we
ignoring good advice or is mobile first
bad advice
similarly to the importance of mobile we
asked developers about their priorities
in other areas and we got them to rank
them we asked this question both in 2020
and in 2021 and got similar answers both
times although security ranked a little
bit higher in 2021
uh but the number one answer both years
was performance and after that uptime
so what we're implicitly saying here is
that we want our websites to be fast and
it's okay if they're down sometimes as
long as they're fast
uh that's an interesting implication
isn't it uh doesn't match your
experience of the web
in the same data security comes third
and compliance comes fifth
so the implication there is that it's
okay for your website to leak data as
long as it stays up and it works fast
and it's okay if it violates privacy
laws as long as it stays up and it works
fast and it's secure
is that right are those the correct
priorities i don't know if they're
correct but they're certainly the
accurate priorities the web is full of
fast websites that break and violate
user privacy and leak data all the time
our final question
about what we're doing is about how big
the audience is that we're doing it for
uh here again people could work on lots
of sites so they could give multiple
answers the most common size of audience
is thousands of users this is by web
standards of scale pretty small
and one of the advantages of jam stack
is that because it's on a cdn it scales
really well to millions of users but
websites at the scale of thousands of
users they don't need that
what they need is performance and uptime
which is another thing that they get
from the cdn
in fact it's very instructive to compare
our audience size data with our
priorities data if performance is your
goal and we say that it is then at scale
caching works really well but at small
user sizes caching isn't going to work
you're going to get a lot of cache
misses and a lot of slow hits so you're
probably going to need to pre-render
things obviously pre-rendering is a
feature of the jam stack so basically
this data is sort of explaining one of
the underlying drivers of the popularity
of jam stack as an architectural model
so now we come to our third section the
real core of our data which is
technology choices uh not who's doing it
or what we're doing but how
we have some special ways of measuring
this uh that it's worth taking a second
to explain
i'm going to show you a bunch of graphs
that look like this
the size of the bubbles is how aware
people are of a technology
how far to the right
is how many people are actually using it
and how high up it is
is a ratio
that we call the satisfaction score uh
if more people want to use your
technology more uh then your
satisfaction score is over 1.0 if your
satisfaction score is less than 1.0 that
means that more people say that they
want to use your technology less than
they do right now
i'll also show you a few graphs like
this which show how these numbers change
from 2020 to 2021.
um
if you go to the right that means you
gained users if you go left you lost
users if you go up your users got
happier if you go down your users got
less happy
you'll see that a very common pattern as
a technology gains users is it loses
satisfaction since early users tend to
be a better fit than later adopters
the first technology choice we looked at
was the start of the process which is
design
this is a great example of how these
graphs work
you can see that everyone has heard of
adobe xd the bubble is huge but usage is
only 36 percent
satisfaction is 1.4 so its users are
happy but figma blows it and everything
else away figma's usage is 62
and its satisfaction score is 8.8
uh nearly everybody else on this graph
is below 1.0 so they have unhappy users
a big category of our questions was
about cms or content management systems
the reason that we spent a lot of time
on it is because of the answer to
another question which was what
third-party apis do you use to put your
site together the most popular one was
authentication but there is no mystery
in that question people use google
facebook twitter and github to log in
the next however was content management
systems and there the field is much more
crowded because there are so many cms we
had to split them up into groups
the first group is traditional cms the
unsurprising leader here is wordpress at
39 usage with drupal at 13 usage
but they both have low satisfaction
scores well under 1.0
there's a newer group called the
headless cms these don't try to provide
any design input they just allow you to
supply and edit content
and they provide an api for you to
incorporate it into your site
wordpress has an api as well and if you
use it in headless mode
it's also very popular and importantly
its satisfaction rises to over 1.0
but in this category contentful is the
leader
and its users are twice as happy as
wordpress
a newer category is what i'm calling the
design led cms these tools make the
visuals of the content a priority and
they provide sophisticated visual
editors often with libraries of
templates to help you get started
a surprise to me
was that the leader here is wix although
its satisfaction is well below 1.0
webflow is both popular and has happy
users as does builder
putting all of those together you can
get a broader picture of the cms space
wordpress is strongest by usage sanity
is strongest by satisfaction
and contentful is the most popular
option that still has happy users uh but
now let's look at year-on-year changes
in this data we weren't tracking
everyone last year so we don't have
everyone's zero new changes but you can
still see some big changes
strappy insanity both gained a lot of
usage and lost steeply in satisfaction
this is that pattern that i mentioned we
would see
keep in mind that they both have very
high absolute satisfaction their users
are very happy they're just less happy
than they were last year
the other obvious change of note
is wordpress which is losing usage
and although its users are unhappy
unsurprisingly
the ones who stuck with it are the ones
who are happiest
what to take away from all of this well
there's no clear leaders in the cms
space but i would say that headless cms
as a category is currently the strongest
one
and contentful is the leader there
with strappy and sanity both strong
options to look at uh if you want a
strong visual editor webflow seems to be
the right choice
our next set of data is about
programming languages and i am not going
to be recommending a programming
language to anyone because everyone's
tastes are very different and very
strong
but it is interesting to see the
breakdown
because the results are something of a
surprise
javascript amongst web developers is
nearly universal at 96
but at 67 the next most used language is
good old sql um typescript comes in very
strong at sixty percent uh and then bash
shell scripting comes in at fifty two
percent
i think the biggest surprise here is
typescript uh typescript claims to be
just javascript
but typescript developers don't seem to
think that
they call themselves typescript
developers they don't call themselves
javascript developers
typescript is at 60 usage overall but 15
of users identify typescript as their
primary programming language over
javascript
while 55 of people say that javascript
is their primary programming language
what about the year-on-year changes in
the language data there's a ton to talk
about here obviously typescript is
gaining a ton of share and its users are
happier than they were before which is
unusual
in the bottom right rust and swift are
gaining users but falling in
satisfaction which is much more like the
usual pattern
in the top left you can see that php is
mostly static
and ruby and beat and bash are both
losing share
and then there's the bottom left
javascript is losing share and losing
satisfaction what is going on there
what i think this shows is a larger
problem for the javascript language
which is that it is over extended if you
want to make a website in 2021 you have
to use javascript or typescript that's
not good it means that people who don't
like javascript people who aren't
they're going to have to use it
even though they hate it
people who aren't happy in a language
are not going to write it well we have
to free the web from javascript
one possible route for doing that is
webassembly or wasm
wasm provides a mechanism for any
programming language to be compiled down
to a simple form that can be executed at
near native speeds inside the browser
uh people have done this with rust and
go and they've even done it with python
and php by including the interpreter
along with the compilation
this is a very exciting development
but what does all this mean for you
well javascript for the moment still
seems to be pretty inescapable but
learning typescript looks like a good
choice
or at least good for your career
i think of typescript as a big project's
choice it is essentially automated
testing
and tests are great as your team scales
up
on smaller projects i prefer javascript
but then i prefer javascript anyway so
what do i know
now for a very quick section we didn't
ask about a lot of back-end technologies
but we were interested in what people
were using
some answers were obvious and
unsurprising containers like docker and
orchestration orchestration like
kubernetes are very popular and lots of
people use microservices
but there was a surprise in this data
and it was serverless functions
uh netlify has built-in support for
serverless functions so obviously we are
big fans but we were not prepared for
the finding that 46
of people say that they are using
serverless functions that is nearly half
of developers
uh
that makes it an extremely mainstream
choice that explains why a lot of the
frameworks that we're about to look at
in the next section have made serverless
functions a first-class feature of their
framework
which brings us to our final and biggest
question which is about web frameworks
there are thousands of them people
constantly argue about them
what's good and what's bad and how to
use them properly but let's step back
for a second first and ask why use a
framework at all
believe it or not there was a time
before web frameworks were invented and
i was a web developer then as well and
i'm here to tell you that it sucked
every company had their own special
snowflake of a web application and they
all did roughly the same thing and they
all did it slightly differently so
hiring somebody to work on your
application
was a process that could take weeks or
months as they slowly learned the
architecture and the idioms that your
company had invented for itself
ruby on rails changed the way the web
development industry works
suddenly your onboarding time was zero
people knew how to build a rails app and
you could just hire somebody who knew
how to build a rails app and it did that
even though ruby had some real
performance problems at the time
the advantage of a framework is not
really a technical one it's a human one
having other people know how your
application works is a massive benefit
it almost doesn't matter what framework
you pick because they'll all help you go
faster more people will help you find
bugs more people will answer questions
more people will ship plugins for it
more people will write documentation for
it but
above all you can hire people who
already know how to work on your app
frameworks may claim to help you scale
your app and some of them may even
actually do that but what they all do
what they definitely do is help you
scale your team
so in our data we asked about 32
different frameworks which is a lot uh
so like cmss we had to split them up
into a couple of groups
the first is a very small crew known as
component libraries these do the very
basics
and you do the rest or use an additional
framework on top of them
the biggest is react and react is huge
67 of people are using it two-thirds
uh we're going to talk more about react
later
but vue is also a very popular choice
and svelte is doing quite well as well
and they all have very high satisfaction
scores people love using component
libraries
then there's static site generators or
ssgs
these are the un frameworks they produce
flat html to the user and little or no
javascript on the client side
but they save you a lot of work on the
server side the current winner in this
category is gatsby uh but we'll see
a little later why that choice might not
be so simple another possibility is
eleventy which is smaller but has huge
satisfaction
the next group is kitchen sink
frameworks
uh because they do everything and the
kitchen sink
the major outliers in this data are
already clear next js which is closely
tied to react has 43 usage and sky-high
satisfaction next which is closely
associated with vue is roughly as
popular relative to next as view is to
react so it's about half at twenty-five
percent
sveltkit is tied to felt obviously uh
and it corresponds roughly to the
popularity of that library at eight
percent
veed is a newcomer and a bit of an
exception because it's not tied to any
particular component library it can work
with react or vue or svelt
and a number of other component models
it can be also be configured to work
like an ssg
which is true several of these kitchen
sinks veed has amazing satisfaction
and usage is already at fourteen percent
uh sveltkit is built on feet
then that data begins to get too crowded
so let's zoom in to these frameworks uh
that have less than ten 10 share uh this
is a mix of very old and very new
frameworks ember media and happy are
older uh redwood.js remix and blitz are
all very new um remix is so new uh that
the public can't even use it yet uh and
yet somehow it has three percent
reported usage uh so i guess the people
in the beta really like it
now let's look at the other type of data
which is the year on year changes uh
first off in the top right react has
grown while maintaining its level of
satisfaction that is a huge
accomplishment when you're already so
big
but next js added more than 20 shares
since last year
and has also managed to improve its
satisfaction score which is incredibly
impressive
over in the bottom right we'll see the
pattern that we've come to expect
eleventy nest preact and view press they
form this neat straight line down into
the right the bigger they got the more
satisfaction that they shed uh the same
happened though less so uh to bigger
frameworks like view and svelt and next
um there were a bunch that didn't change
much and then there was gatsby which
unfortunately shed users and
satisfaction
which i think makes your choice of ssg
in 2021 a little bit harder
one thing that i'm not tracking in this
data that i promise to do a better job
of in future is tracking usage of web
components uh browsers have native
support for web components and there are
some famous large scale implementations
of them but it's quite a distributed
ecosystem and hard to track so it's been
kind of a blind spot for me um their
usage is somewhere well under 10 right
now but they may finally be getting some
traction so i'm keeping my eye on them
so it's time to think about what all of
this means for us is there a clear
winner in frameworks i don't think so
but there are some obvious strong
choices a component library of some kind
is a good idea everybody likes using
them and the strongest of those is react
if you're looking for a kitchen sink
next.js is the clear leader next is a
strong competitor and vit and sveltkit
are very interesting options
but because of the performance data that
we were looking at earlier you may not
want a kitchen sync framework an ssg
might be a better choice for you in
which case gatsby is the obvious choice
but given its declining satisfaction and
usage you might want to try 11t instead
the last thing i want to mention when
i'm talking about frameworks is a
potential future for react as we saw
react is enormous way bigger than its
nearest competitor and also bigger than
anything else out there
the only framework that i'm aware of
that was ever bigger than react is now
was jquery and that is an important
historical parallel
because jquery never died people say
that they don't use jquery anymore but
that's because something happened
browser makers took the apis that jquery
invented and built them straight into
the browser you don't need to install
jquery anymore it is built into the
fabric of the web 100 of people use
jquery it didn't die it transcended
could something like that happen to
react i can't say for certain but what
happens if react goes from 67 share to
or 80 or 90
at what at some point the browser makers
probably need to stop and think about
how to bring these idioms to the native
web platform
native web components are portable and
extremely performant but react's
developer experience is extremely
popular i would really like to see
somebody combine these two
so that was a ton of data so i told you
i'd give you a sense of the state of
modern web development how did i do
let's quickly recap
we learned that b2b and b2c are equally
big but other categories that we spend
less effort on like internal tools and
lead capture are almost equally big
targets of our work
speaking of targets we learned that we
don't target mobile as much as that we
as we say that we should
and also that we target that we build
totally static sites and completely
dynamic sites roughly equally often we
learned that move fast and break things
is apparently the industry's standard
priority
and finally in how we build we learned
that strappy and sanity are making waves
and that lenti is a static site
generator to look out for we learned
that react is becoming bedrock to the
web and that next.js is a front-runner
in frameworks veet is an outstanding
newcomer
and we talked about the future will we
switch to native web components will
wasm play a role we don't know
but if you take nothing else away
what i hope you get from this is how
exciting the web is right now there are
new tools and technologies and
techniques and they are constantly
pushing the boundaries of what the web
can do
and we are the lucky ones who get to
play with them and build it i hope you
find that thought as invigorating as i
do and thank you all for your time and
attention